I write with my left hand I destroy with
my right are you left-handed I write
left-handed it's only thing I do
left-handed that's bizarre yeah you
throw right-handed yeah really yeah
what are you jack right can you do left
though yeah like a pencil though no I
did I jerk I have a different I
have a different release
[Music]
well it's bo staff day to here at the
bonfire has the energy changed yes I
think it has feels a lot more secure the
bonfire Comedy Central radio sirius XM
95 on big Jay oakerson that handsome
sumbitch Dan Soder how are you also
known as tomahawk Tom E ha Tommy Hahn
tag Tommy Tommy hawk I was Anthony
Anthony Hawkins in big J Bo oakerson big
Jay oakerson big J Bo Carson put you
over the bow Kirsten that works much
better I'll tell you this you're a bo
staff guy me being a hatchet man also
known as a tomahawk um I see why you
like it I think I use it more for hiking
and moving but I don't I think it's your
look and I kind of want to respect that
right here you know I have it for
security reasons that was a real long
journey so you don't want to hold the
staff anymore and I'm gonna put mine
down too damn because I don't want to
intimidate everybody cuz you know how
good my skills with the post staff are I
think down so I don't worry but for you
guys cuz I don't want to hold any Jay
listen no I'm committing to the bo staff
good I hope oh we have a phone call
coming later that this post is gonna
come in real handy with and by the way
whoever's on 35 you
[Music]
it's Marilyn suck our dicks Merrill
Lynch the salacious hour do you remember
yeah you asked me if I've ever filmed
myself having sex and I responded
quickly once on an old digital camera
with my ex-girlfriend and then we
watched it and immediately deleted it
cuz you didn't know I didn't realize
what you look like oh you want with her
yeah we like filmed it and then
we were like laying in bed and we're
like smoking cigarettes because she used
be able smoking her apartment god she
was the best mistake bro shadow show
never shown what no she knew we were
filming I know I didn't say I would
assume I'm gonna pull the plug I was
like huh
that's what I looked like there's look
like a white blob on top of her just but
my bottom half humping into right now
but even if it's going real just don't
show it don't want to get it don't watch
it together I also watched it post for
gasm per load so I was like more like Oh
what are we doing and it was like you
see the side of yourself and you don't
realize what that looks like and it is
not good well I was hired at least on me
when I saw it I was like eh
oh so our car our topic is if you have
any filming yourself or someone
and it just goes haywire warming up or
looking at the video and just seeing how
awful a thing was my big revelation joke
of where I never
I had that one that was bad me on top of
my she was so tiny that you say it was
the independence they ship the shadow
camera it was timely everybody ever
doing comedy for a zillion years ten
years you've been working here for ten
years whoever's gonna post and ten years
I've been working boast after ten years
everything I do now is gonna be ten
years you know when like a little kid
hears something and they just hold on to
it and they're like two weeks two weeks
everything for me now seven years eight
for for comedy nine she's number to call
in if you want to tell your misstep
mishap story welcome to mine I should
film my girlfriend blowing me from the
top mm-hmm
bad angle bud real well it was that
angle wasn't great the POV but it was
okay okay and that but I was like when I
see the video later I'm gonna and this
is like Sony Handycam days oh dude that
so you could hear it move those POV
tapes like shanesworld oh yeah this
makes me happy to think that I don't
know I don't believe this would happen
anymore at my size now but maybe it
would I don't know but I thought I
always thought she was like okay a
blowjob I don't have a very big dick and
I she really couldn't pin it you know I
mean I didn't take it all the way and
yeah her mouth but she could just wasn't
very good and I was like she was just
bad at it when I filmed her from the
side this poor girl what I found out was
that every time she goes to put my dick
deeper into her mouth my stupid
belly girls are in the forehead oh man
it's like an ox oh she's getting knocked
back constantly ah now it's like trying
to watch a bird fly inside through a
window what exchange go to the to the
drinking fountain
they really close it off is this low I
have a question because it could be
spelled is it that would be windy
they say swear to god that was a cure
man oh dude that's the guy that I told
you I met him after a show at the
punchline and he goes what's up man I'm
Dugan I go oh yeah like Jays joke in the
elevator like you guys go to Duggan's
rager and guess what that's like nothing
that's cool dudes on the line
Duke and Sactown crackle dibs of doobs
you driving the gremlin tearing up the
roads
man you go down to beers yes but
no female nudity only males
no I was okay with that so I went
upstairs into the bedroom she had this
really sexy black wig on and it's very
nice sundress proceeded to do all kinds
of great things to me I got the camera
phone out started to go and record it
and I forgot she had the wig on and went
and grabbed your hair in the wig
came off last night drop the camera and
it was a fairly embarrassing but funny
you should have kept the camera on her
and then said another name as you pulled
the wig where you went this entire time
you were what does this music can you
play this after everyone's story
oh oh you ever take the wig off as that
role plays much more welcome to
salacious phone calls on the bonfire
that's a yeah cuz then you start
laughing you're like well we got to hang
this up that's not good yeah their hairs
all matted down from the wig well it's
always weird when people like nail the
filming like that guy that sent us clips
of him double-teaming that chick with
like there's like professionally shot
where you're like how did you he sent us
one video I didn't see the butt video
but the video he sent us of her blowing
that you're like dude he's like a
professional crew in there look he was
sawing or ass him to like light soft
lighting like they have to come in to
camera crew that's filming us now so
coming here in like Matt the lighting so
it looks about that bad
you know much tissue it takes to get
this production off the graph a lot a
whole box of Kleenex um let's take
another take we have a Canadian caller
what do you think in Canadian sex tape
mishap could be Dan I was on ice
whatever it's so nice yeah then she
slipped on the ice and she put her two
through my dick oh no sorry
marky-mark in Canada what's up buddy
you're on the bonfire is everybody
calling from a field calm down do you
need air support are you out there give
your location give your location I need
you to shoot the flare right now mark if
you want us to take out Charlie you need
us to let us know where you are
also shout out to Sarah my pants hashtag
counselor ten years we go sniff oh sorry
geez Jacobs looking alright D
Scorsese over here sorry we shot the
style that you know staff day most I
don't wave in front of my face you even
saw us so fast deaf with this thing
you're lucky I just spared all your
lives to ever watch that clip sorry mark
sorry mark mark you know you and your ex
we're gonna make a sex tape yeah
I live up in the oil industry in Fort
McMurray Alberta hell yeah
so we got some pretty trashy girls up
here is that near Calgary I'm going to
Calgary to weekend believe it's near
Edmonton
yeah Calgary's our shows that nine five
hours north
oh right in the middle huh Canadian
knowledge albert is a big providence i
admittin it's in between Edmonton and
Calgary did you know that for real I'm
north five hours north no but your
father's north I didn't know that at all
I don't know yeah guess so you're on a
good face to make crazy eyes we have a
good face to just be like yeah that's
that's my I was raised by a
single mom but say you got out of
everything it was confidence my mom's
like did you did you just three
cookies right off the sheeting we have
rats in here so anyways you're you're in
a desolate well you're in a remote town
yeah and where we make all the oil hell
yeah have fossil fuel awesome what's up
damn you are up there we're looking at a
map right now
yeah way up there some guy rolled
his transport truck today and his
excavator blew off and blocked the
highway
dude same thing happened to me on my
block in Queens crazy I'm skimming yes
so what happened hopefully my ex isn't
listening but if she is
what's up Marcy shoutout Marta see you
[Music]
so all right so what happened so I like
to leave it like the 80s and go all Bush
and bear down on me at my parents place
and you know we were drinking and
smoking and well let's just say she kind
of looks like her brother and when she
had me all the way in looked like her
brother with a beard
hilarious but but you weren't filming
this right this was just you just
realizing that Oh his dick hair
is so long that it made it look like
yeah yeah it made it look like she had a
goatee she's exactly like her brother
yeah and then she later then he popped
immediately yeah exactly like her
brother when he sucks my dick oh my god
you and your brother have the same eyes
when I'm all the way down your throat
weird
you both get the same way do ya weird
you know that you're I don't know if
that's a family secret or no how do you
you know that's weird their guide flex
must not be in your family that's a good
mishap that was filmed wow
how about James in Texas this sounds
like this is juicier wow this is pretty
crackle buddy Valentine's Day
and I'd like rolled out the red carpet I
got the hotel room with the Rose pillows
roll out was the hotel was the hotel a
residence in got myself the red carpet
right need wine sick go back go
big get minis so I popped up the phone
on the TV and I recorded it and I put it
in one of those apps that has like a
it's like a photo and video bulk so went
on like the camera or a photo real on
the phone yeah you went dark with it
yeah in 16 or whatever yeah yeah you had
to scramble the signal yeah right and so
I I ended up we gave that phone to her
son because he had cracked is and I'd
already upgraded and I guess we didn't
delete the app off of this and so he
moved the passcode and he saw it and so
at first the video
kind of it's like her on top and it's
just showing like you know the balls to
Athens yeah the Gooch I guess on me the
couch steps off all Gooch minutes in I
get up from like drinking 15 whiskey's
on you know trying to hit it doggystyle
so I can get my rocks off and I had a
blue pill man yeah you're Ivan Drago
innit you're all jacked up on
steroids
a little bit of a far after how he see
her son this is not your kid he was her
son how old was he 15 oh I'm wrecking
his mom okay you call you clot him at a
moment where he is either gonna be one
hell of an artist or a needle drug user
possibly both is it was his mom hot like
is it something where his like friends
like would be like blown away by that
you could probably run off to if you
were I mean I guess back in the day now
they can you know yeah they can see they
could see some live yeah I know
what you're talking about don't like a
nice 96 cleavage see and then you're
like I'm home and offices yeah it's
where you can see the little like the
cupcake outline where like kind of fake
boobs shows you where it separates
makes it easy said mom with fake boobs
yeah there's been a lot of seed spilled
in that region near that house and in
that friendship that spilled a lot of
seed and this really him up he's
gonna be into some sick
I don't know choking maybe getting beat
up was his mom like a real noise maker
in the video is she like losing it yeah
she was pretty happy with the the rose
petals and all the stuff that's across
with so put on a performance
oh I Judas blatant honesty he
goes as she appreciated the rose petals
so she act like I took her to pound
townn is that the name of the file was
it like slams ville population one and
he goes what slams oh my god mom and
dear mom and James are getting
back down this is mom lessons while
she's getting
I think that could either jerked off to
it or he's gonna become a serial killer
I mean dude that's both of those things
fold into each other yourself James
Dean's plays in his head and he goes uh
enjoy the phone asshole as he's leaving
this into a cup of chili I think this is
woody here is everybody just choose a
different tone and keep saying James
with us right now everybody lose
everyone and now on the light
heavyweight champion of the world
everyone becomes James
I mean Oh ceramic pan dude James thanks
so much for calling in and also thanks
for everyone hilarious that
kid that guy's so goddamn funny
sometimes cars calling you it did you're
funny dude he's like you know I'm firing
off the line I'm like do I want to
come off the wagon for this dude
you just drink a six-pack of beer with
James at an airport I don't want to go
nowhere if we ever officially talk to
our MMA fighter on the air Dustin
organized Anderson he's gotta call him
sometime
yeah I mean our our head of Security's
Mickey call but you're talking about
Dustin or oh no the guy from Madison
Madison yeah yeah he's gotta call it
well you said he wanted to come in the
studio yo yeah but might have to be like
that yes coming like earlier for a free
report I think Sarah my pants tweeting
I've made videos from my boyfriend when
he's away and nothing makes you go from
feeling horny to seeing yourself yeah I
know that's absolutely true Sarah I
usually just fire I don't ever put my
face in it you just come you send it to
me yeah that's it JD delete it JD's
wants to see the shot that I deleted
curl up in a ball might tries to comfort
me I'm all about the shot the shot all
about the shot poor shot plough you
wanna take our last break uh Wow yeah
sure yeah come back we'll talk more sex
tape mishaps if we keep coming in i'll
buddy we're lighting up the lines are
lighting up calling with yours black
lose waiting here your salacious filth
dude yet but also I wanted this story's
perfectly okay ooh yes so anxious yeah
it is so late it's another salacious
hour the bonfire we've been here for so
long we'll be right back everybody
bonfire before we take the cars when I
basically say what I think is being said
here and I want Kevin from Texas to
essentially give me a one-word answer
here because this makes me so this has
been making me laugh too goddamn good
but you were saying this cause been
making you laugh on the call screen just
now wrote it up and I hope it's just the
right answer here it says and just just
say yes if I'm right about what's being
described here unless I'm wrong kevin
says he made a sex video with an X
showed it to coworkers bragging Lee I'm
assuming not knowing that one of the
co-workers was their cousin you wish you
had titties like there goes my cousin's
titties II mean you know that's just
like that's a hard shoots in there
behind your brain you think
about hitting the cousin oh man check
out this pig those are ankles behind
their ears he goes that's my baby cousin
you know what Jared that's a caver after
her mom died who you sister than a
cousin now you can't go to HR with
anything dudes getting bullied at work
like so much have you been did
it how long did you work with the guy
after do you still work with them and me
and one of my other co-workers we got an
apartment together and my bedroom had a
look there the clouds they had two
minutes the same co-worker was like oh
man you should give yourself you know
the turnstile signs that while you
hidden it and so that's what I did and I
was showing him the video and then he
said that's my second tragedy the dudes
I dare he goes here's regime dude super
awesome you're banging a chick
he Patrick Bateman her you film it show
to me oh my god that's what he's saying
he's saying he told him how to his
cousin's not knowing it was cuz that's
exactly what I'm saying
that's like he goes buddy promise me one
thing you will shove your thumb in the
next pig's butt that you oh my god
that's my baby sister Melissa little
Laurie no I saved her from a well
you